foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
ldlr related receptors are evolutionary
conserved cellular receptors for
Divergent Alpha viruses this webinar is
part of the microbiology virtual week
and I'm Susie Valdez of Labyrinth and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots so let's get
started before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this
the event is interactive and we
encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation now you can find that live
chat located at the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you want during
this presentation to do so simply type
them in
to the ask a question box and click
submit we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
question now if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
just click on the help desk button
located at the bottom of your screen
within the navigation bar or from the
lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits I now
present today's speaker Dr Jonathan
Abraham assistant professor of
microbiology at Harvard Medical School
for a complete biography of our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen Dr Abraham welcome
you may now begin your presentation sir
got some of our Labs work
um
thank you
the opportunity to tell you about some
of our Labs work so the title of my
presence
presentation is ldlr related receptors
or evolutionary conservative cellular
receptors for Divergent Alpha viruses
and so we'll start off with some
background on Alpha viruses these are
arthropor-born enveloped RNA viruses
um that fall into two main groups uh old
world and new world and this is
based on their serology and geographic
distribution
they tend to uh when they infect humans
cause two types of illnesses either
fever rash and arthritis or Encephalitis
and by that I mean inspection of the
pain
and the case fatality rate is
particularly high for the alpha viruses
that cause
Encephalitis and so uh to give you an
example of one of these viruses that
some of you might have heard of
um more featured in the news back in
2019 is Eastern equine Encephalitis
virus this virus caused us outbreak in
2019 before covid-19 pandemic that
affected about 34 people in
um
seven different states though the case
mythology rate for this impression is
quite High about 50 of the people who
get infected can die from infection and
those that survive unfortunately end up
uh in many cases with permanent
neurological sequelae which means that
they require
institutionalized care
um thereafter
uh so the burden of this illness on uh
Healthcare can be quite High
particularly should this virus cause a
pandemic
and so uh Eastern acquire encephalitis
virus here I'm showing you an example of
how this virus is Amplified and
maintained in nature the virus can be
carried by mosquitoes where it
replicates and ultimately the
blood meal can infect the bird uh in
this case
serving as a reservoir birds can then
affect additional mosquitoes so this
cycle can be effectively a Reservoir in
nature for the virus to be Amplified but
then when the bridge Vector here shown
on the right part of the blood is able
to get a blood meal from both a bird but
then a dead host
including humans are horses this is
where you get highly lethal disease
and I should note that there are
actually no vaccine or drugs
against Alpha virus infection
and so the structural protein is
subdivided into uh six polypeptides as
the protein matures there is an
n-terminal capsid envelope glycoprofen
fragments E3 E1 E2 and 6K E1 and E2 are
really the business and I'll be telling
you about today during representation E3
is a chaperone for E1 and E2 and E1 and
E2 associate as dimers of
um of trimers that form icons
iconsahedral cell on the surface of the
virus which is still on the right part
of the slide
here so you will see there that there's
a outer layer in this case shown in blue
and the inner layer shown in Orange so
these are the trimers of the E2 E1
glycoproteins
um so classically it's been thought that
E2 has most of the ability to bind
cellular receptors and E1 is what
mediates Fusion of the viral and host
cell membranes after viral particles are
internalized into acid
find endosomes although some structural
analysis recently suggest that both E1
and E2 actually are both participating
in our sub finding
and so we started this project in our
lab back in 2018
um at the time not much was known about
cellular receptors that allowed Alpha
viruses to enter cells uh that being
said uh the Advent of crispr cast 9
screens and the robust uh genetic uh
approach this offered to find receptors
for viruses meant that multiple Labs had
been working on identifying uh receptors
for these viruses and so in this case
um you can see that uh for the virus MX
uh the virus chikungunya virus
um mxra8 could serve as a cellular
receptor my apologies about that
um so mxra8 is a matrix remodeling
Associated protein
um that plays a uh poorly described role
in the biology of joints
and so in this case the lab of Mike
Diamond with collaborators they were
able to find that
um
mxra
Associates with the survival Spike
protein by binding a cleft that is
formed by E1 and E2
in this case you can see that the E1
protein is shown in Orange and the E2
glycoprotein is shown in blue
mxra8 is the molecule on the right side
of the slide that is shown in purple
and so we set out to use a crispr cast 9
screens to identify receptors for some
of the encephalitic alpha viruses
because at the time no Cellar receptors
were known for these viruses so a lot of
these agents are actually bsl-3
pathogens and so in order to be able to
study them safely what we had to do is
develop a system that allowed us to have
effectively the ability to
stereotype the virus so that it enters
cells uh
and not replicate the spread to infect
other cells and the way we did this is
we took the genome for an alpha virus
that's actually a bsl2 pathogen Ross
River virus
in this case you could see that the
genome is subdivided into four
non-structural proteins and SP one two
three and four as well as the structural
proteins in this case capsid E3 E2 6K TF
and E1
hopefully you can see then that uh as a
strategy what we're able to do is split
this uh genome into two segments uh one
encoding a plasmid that has the genome
but whereby the glycoprotein has been
deleted and replaced by a reporter that
is Downstream of a 2A peptide so in this
case the reporter is uh gfp if we want
to do facts to monitor viral entry or
order reporter could be cd20 as I'll
tell you on the next slide we could use
that as a marker of a cell being
infected uh but being
able to track self-surface expression
allows us then to take infected cells
and deplete them using beads against uh
against that marker and so this plasmic
2 here in this case could be instead of
the Ross River envelope glycoprotein
could be the glycoprotein for Eastern in
Quant Encephalitis virus or could be the
glycoprotein for additional Alpha
viruses we were interested in studying
and so we use this system to design a
crispr cast 9 screen that's shown on
this slide in this case we have guide
rnas
um that are translucent to cells uh this
is followed by pure mice and selection
uh once pure medicine selection happens
all cells should have uh the way we set
up the experiment a single guide
targeting a
in the visual protein we take these
cells
uh we challenge them with rvps or
reported virus particles that Express
cd20 being again this cell surface
marker in this case what you'll see is
that I'm showing you
uh as these little yellow marks on the
cells that are infected with C20 uh rvps
um uh effectively cell surface
expression of this marker and then we
use magnetic beads to deplete the cd20
positive cell
after that only cells that are resistant
meaning cells that contain guides that
knocked out potential receptor
candidates are carried through and so to
increase the signal to noise of the
assay we can do this multiple times and
at the end we use Next Generation
sequencing to quantify
um the uh both the relative prevalence
of guides as well as uh the total amount
of reads per guide using next-gen
sequencing so another trick we used here
uh is that to only focus on proteins
that would probably be cell surface
receptors we did not do a genome-wide
screen but instead designed our screen
so that each guide would only target
proteins that are suspected or known to
be membrane Associated so this meant
that the total genes we were targeting
were about only 4 400 genes in total and
because of the way the library could be
designed at the time
and it also meant that we could use more
guides per jeans or more genome white
screens have six to eight guides per
Gene we had 10 guides uh per membrane
Associated protein in this assay
and so we first validated the screen
using viruses that had known cellular
receptors
I'm including loss of virus which is an
arena virus and lujo virus which is
another Arena virus and so we were quite
confident that there was this approach
could yield a very robust results and so
when we carried out the screen with some
leaky Forest virus but
which is an old world Alpha virus that
interestingly enough has been reported
to cause a case of encephalitis in
humans wants but is known to cause
Encephalitis in animals including
neonatal mice as well as Horses
um the top hit in the screen uh here
shown
um with an rra score which is uh based
on the bioinformatic pipeline related to
how often the guide is present
in that final population I was telling
you about on the last slide
uh from the next sequencing results as
well as how many guides per Gene
um are found 10 out of 10 guides were
found for vldlr and there were very high
recounts for that guide and vldlr stands
for the very low density lipoprotein
related receptor
um it is a top one transmembering
glycoprotein that has a central job of
bringing into cells of the very low
density life of protein
it's also expressed in the central
nervous system where it is a receptor
for Reelin uh and this molecule along
how much Reelin ultimately helps
orchestrate the laminated structures
that occur in the developing
um brain of mammals and so uh a second
hit on the screen was HSP 90b1
interestingly enough this protein is a
chaperone for another protein called
pcsk9 which is a master regulator of
ldlr related receptors
then scd-3a was the only other
statistically significant hit this
is a protein that is um involving the
replication of other positive sense RNA
viruses are flirty viruses but I had not
been known to be implicated in the
entry or replication of alpha viruses
and so everything Downstream of this now
including the chrm1 these were actually
within the range that we knew based on
our pilot studies uh would actually not
uh be statistically significant or
relevant
so when you're really focusing on vldlr
um I should add that vldlr is also a
receptor for other viruses including
minor group human rhinoviruses as well
as a vesticular stomatitis virus so um
the fact that it was also receptive for
other viruses made us even more
confident that it would probably be
playing a real world real world in the
entry of this particular Alpha of Iris
and so the usual experiment we do to
validate any receptor is to take wild
type cells in this case hectare T cells
knock out the receptor uh using specific
guides this time targeting the receptor
only and then showing that rescuing
expression of the receptor using cdna
encoding vldlr can actually lead to uh
you know uh could lead to robust entry
in this case so correcting for the
defect that was seen by
by uh individual knockout of the target
Gene
and so an additional experiment we
wanted to do because some leaky Forest
virus interestingly enough is known to
infect multiple subtypes um
this has actually made a candidate for
uh gene therapy as well as vaccines
because it's been known to affect
multiple cell types so we wanted to know
whether or not this ability to use vld
alone was related to the tissue tropism
of this virus so if you see in this case
if we take cells treated with no
antibody an anti-vldlr antibody or an
anti-haa antibody being there are
negative control you could see that we
could block entry into 293 T cells
and then when we try the cells derived
from long
liver lymphoid and Bone we've had
similar results a bone was interesting
because uh for those cell types we saw
only about uh 40 to 50 reduction in
entry suggestion tool that perhaps they
might be alternate receptors on the
style type or alternate path
ways of Entry
and then lastly the most relevant uh
cell type would be neurons so these are
two immoralized neuronal cell lines we
saw that an antibody against of ldlr
again
I could robustly block the entry of
seminiki forest virus
and so the next set of experiments we
wanted to do was to Define exactly where
the virus might be attaching onto the
receptor and so the receptors organized
again as a type 1 transmembrane protein
I'm not showing here the cytoplasmic
tail they would be below the cell
membrane here
um the n-terminal portion
the receptor here which are most
membrane distal have a series of
cysteine-rich modules called ldlr Class
A repeats or La repeats
that are around in tandem here and very
slightly from each other in sequence but
all uh coordinated calcium and
ultimately are what comprise a ligand
binding domain that is what binds to
vldl and Reelin and then in red and in
green I'm showing you the EGF like
module that is not involved in receptive
and ligand binding as well as an old
linked domain here that has holding
sugars in yellow
and so the map where the virus might
bind we decided to generate two
additional constructs where we either
deleted the ligand binding domain or
deleted the egl EGF like domain and keep
the ligand binding domain intact and
repeated these expression experiments in
k562 cells which are cells we found were
highly resistant to infection
um to see whether or not we'd be able
to
um Define exactly where the virus was
binding
and so what you'll see here in this case
is we have wild Pet Key factors to two
cells I'll should add that these are
chronic myelogenous leukemia
you have the right cell line that's
poorly differentiated and whatever Alpha
virus we've thrown at them usually
there's very little to no background
entries so what this is what you can see
here with the wild type K factors do
cells there no gfp
positive cells when we challenge these
cells with symmetic forms virus RVP
the vldlr ortholog human ortholog when
expressed in these cells allowed for
robust entry mostly deleted the ligand
binding domain that's the next column
over we saw loss of Entry uh when we
deleted the EGF light domain
but not the like and buying domain we
saw that entry was restored and the nrp2
flag in this case is a negative control
uh receptor this is receptive producer
neutral rockers uh unrelated virus and
so disconnected to us that
the virus was actually associating with
the ligand binding domain that contains
these uh Sistine Rich ldlr Class A
repeats
and so
we sort of then uh started to think
really hard about the implications of
this because this was the first time an
ldlr related member was identified as a
receptor for a an alpha virus at the
time we're doing these studies and I
think when one is looking at a family of
viruses that are related to each other
and perhaps called similar
pathophysiology I didn't mention to you
there's you know Venezuelan
Encephalitis virus that also causing
Encephalitis in humans and horses I
mentioned to you Eastern equine
Encephalitis there's also Western equine
Supply so these all these viruses that
have related E1 and E2 glycoproteins so
one of the first questions we wanted to
answer is rather announce vldlr was a
receptor only for some linky Forest
virus or might be a receptive for some
of these other Alpha viruses including
old world and um New World Alpha viruses
another thing I should add is at the
functional level vldlr
has a close homologue in the brain
called April er2 which is also a
receptor for relin and so vldlr and A4
er2 are very closely overlapping in
their tissue distribution in the brain
and their function as veline receptor is
important in neural development
so the next set of
experiments and we'll show you only the
ones that worked we tried to see if we
took k552 cells
sfv or eev or synvis are related old
world Alpha viruses on k552 cells here
in this case expressing mxra8 the
chicken dunia receptor we saw no entry
but when we expressed
vldlr or two isoforms of a poor er2 all
of a sudden we saw a very robust entry
I'm not showing you this here but uh
vldlr and A4 er2 are also related to
ldlr which is uh LDL receptor
effectively that's perhaps the best
studied member of the family so ldlr did
not work but vldlr and April er2 did
function as receptors for these three
Alpha viruses which has an additional
Alpha viruses and saw no effect on Entry
and so I think a key important aspect of
whenever receptors identified for a
virus a family is to demonstrate an
interaction between a recombinant
protein and uh the viral glycoprid so it
was a carbonate receptor fragment I
should say and the viral protein and the
way we did these assays is we took
current UT cells transfected with the E2
E1 oval of glycoproteins and then stain
these cells with FC Fusion proteins that
either contain the VL
blr ligand binding domain if used to an
FC segment so that we can stain with
anti-fc antivirus to detect cell surface
binding of these constructs or mxra8 in
this case which are control protein
which is a receptor for chikungunya
virus as I mentioned identified by Mike
Diamond's group
over at Washington University in St
Louis
and so this is a control hair cells
transpected with chikungunya
E2 E1
will actually bind the mxr8
uh mxr8fc fusion protein but not the DL
DLR FC fusion protein but when we did a
similar experiment but instead what
hacking activity cells over expressing
some Mickey Forest
um
Eastern equine Encephalitis or synvis
viruses we saw the reverse effects
whereby the vldlr FC fusion protein
was binding to cells but not the mxra8
FC fusion protein so they're secreted to
us that indeed
um our FC Fusion proteins containing the
ligand binding domain for a vldlr was
the molecular determinant that allowed
direct binding to the envelope protein
but I think you know one aspect of ldlr
receptors is that they of course bind
lipoproteins and so the experiments we
have done up until this point did not uh
confirm that the association between the
envelope glycoprotein and the ligand
binding domain was a direct one you can
imagine that even in these binding
studies if our lb DFC fusion protein is
able to bind lipoproteins and serum
um and that that complex and Associates
with e2e1 that we'd still see binding
um I'll give you an example that vldlr
has been implicated cellular entry of
hepatitis C virus but for that virus for
example it's thought to be actually an
indirect association with lipoproteins
that are decorating the viral particles
so all that being said we wanted to try
to use as purest possible preparations
to demonstrate and direct interaction
between the vldlr LBD and the E2 E1
proteins of alpha viruses
and so the way we did these essay is we
uh first relied on a system that allowed
us to make virus-like particles so these
are uh particles that again recapitulate
the iconsahedral symmetry of the actual
virus and can simply be produced by
trisecting in the structural proteins uh
under a CMD promoter at the cells
and so we were able to get these very
nice virus-like particles the scale bar
here is about 100 nanometers the virus
is supposed to be 70 nanometers and then
we examine these under the electron
microscope I did not see evidence of
associated Library
proteins we also took these particles uh
that were purified and submitted to them
to mass spec where we did not identify
any evidence of associated lipoprotein
peptide so this occurred to us that we
had very pure preparations
and so for binding essays we use a
technique called biolayer interferometry
uh in this case what we have is a sensor
tip that is dipped into a solution that
allows them to capture either via DLR or
APO er2fc Fusion proteins or the control
mxra
uh Ecto domain and so when these sensor
tips uh bind uh to First the slide end
and then they're dipped into a separate
solution that contains an analyte in
this case virus-like particles you would
see binding uh but the way this actually
was done which is really a competition
asset we first pre-dip the tips into
buffer and then vlps so with the under
the vldlr graph the left side of the
graph you'll see that when the vldlr
coated tips were dipped into buffering
and vlps we saw a response on the y-axis
suggested about binding our receptor
substituted protein is a ligand
antagonist so when we pre-dipped vldlr
into rock containing solution
um and then The Binding assay we saw a
decrease of binding to vlps when we
pre-dipped the Via
of the LR coordinate tips and the
solution containing transferrin uh we
did not see a decrease in Signal
transparent here was our negative
control and you can see at the next
set of bar uh columns here with buffer
up and transparent for April ER to ISO
one uh we also saw a decrease in binding
with graph so this allowed us to say
that the the interaction between vldlr
and um APO ER to ligand binding domains
with vlps was a direct one not
requiring intermediate association with
virus-like particles not the interaction
uh was specific because it could be
inhibited by a receptor
binding antagonist that is known to bind
the ligand binding domain this fat
protein shown here
and so uh another step that is important
to demonstrate Beyond just the direct
Association is that this punitive
receptor would allow internalization of
particles into cells and so again we
relied on our trusted capacity to cells
which
um unless again over expressing
receptors we found are non-permissive to
offer virus infection so in this case
what I'm showing you are images obtained
from lifestyle and focal microscopy
there's an X
X Y Slice on the left and the 3D Volume
on the right uh in green you're seeing
wheat gene or wheat germ or gluten in
which is a cell surface membrane marker
and in pink you're seeing fluorescent
labeled vlps and so we're able to see if
you look at the top set of uh images
it's 400
trees we saw what seemed to be
Association of vlp to the cell surface
uh when we drop increase the temperature
to 37 then we saw internalization of
virus land particles into cells
and so we were able to work with a
fantastic uh fantastic lifestyle focal
microscope
um at Harvard Medical School and the
Micron core to then quantify the number
of particles that were internalized
around the cell surface and hopefully
you can see that key buckets two cells
are we're expressing vlr at four degrees
have a number of vlps per cell shown on
the y-axis bowel and at 37 degrees
inside the cytoplasmic fraction the next
set of
um
uh next part of the graph here under
vldlr cyto you'll see that the particles
are seemingly internal at 37 degrees
so these are all experiments we were
able to repeat with both synvis virus
and Eastern inquire Encephalitis virus
as well as incorporating an mxra8
control here
showing again that overexpression of
this receptor set allowed both vlp
binding and interpolation into cells
which would be consistent with their
role as bona fide a cellular receptors
and so now to address the physiological
relevance of the association I mentioned
to you that's finicky Forest virus
causes Encephalitis and neonatal mice
vldlr and A40 are too interestingly
enough or overexpressed on on neurons
during development and so we worked with
the lab of Isaac Chu who isolates uh
cortical neurons from neonatal Pups Day
Zero so in this case the true lab has a
protocol to be able to maintain these in
core and culture and maybe it doesn't
project well here but you can actually
see dendrites in this case
um between these cortical neurons so
when we uh incubated the neurons with no
protein and then added sfv rvps we saw
robust infection here with the no
protein image shown at the top left when
we added the receptor uh antagonist wrap
or vldlr lbdfc fusion protein we saw
inhibition of RVP infection and we
didn't see that with the isotope control
and the
is data now are Quantified on the bar
graph on the right so there it looked
like wrap or vldlr FC Fusion proteins or
a Decor receptor could both
um inhibit entry of rvps into a
physiologically relevant cell type
so we then worked with the lab of Scott
Weaver to test
um
whether or not administration of a VL
DLR lbdc fusion protein could block
infection and lethal Encephalitis in
neonatal mice infected with some Nicky
Forest virus so as you can see here
hopefully with the
gray and uh sort of a black line thing
with PBS and I spot control sfv
infection of um day seven mice is almost
is uniformly lethal within three days
all mice that were challenged with sfv
and treated either with PBS or I have
control uh rapidly succumb to infection
uh but with a single administration of
the vldlr lbdfc fusion protein about six
hours before a viral challenge we saw
robust levels of protection
um ultimately such that at day three 100
of the mice were still alive and we
still did see uh you know sort of
delayed death in this case but they eat
all the animals that come to infection
but I should add we had not done any
careful
um studies to look at pharmacokinetics
to figure out whether or not
administration of repeated doses uh
meaning they you know six hours before
infection and then repeat on day one and
day two and day three whether or not
that would have had an increased benefit
of survival but in this case this is a
very robust model that's uniform and
lethal and we did see a statistically
significant effect with protection uh
using the receptor Decor protein which
is again consistent with the role of
this association between vldlr and A4
er2 as a determinant of the
pathophysiology of symmetic forest
virus in um neonatal mice
and so taking us
to step back to what I was talking about
in the beginning of this uh my
presentation you know it's interesting
that these viruses are able to infect
these mosquito vectors so arthropods uh
are able to inspect birds are able to
infect horses and humans and so you know
the possibility that these viruses are
using A lipoprotein receptor as their
main way of entering cells was quite uh
quite an attractive hypothesis because
several of the proteins are for example
important for carrying and leading to
the uptake of lipid
is inside the gut of a mosquito or also
related to the molecules that bind uh
lipids in the serum of birds and humans
and horses so uh ldlr family members are
quite conserved across various domains
of life
and so the graduate student in the lab
Lars Clark had the idea of cloning out
vldlr and apoor2 orthologies from
multiple species to test the hypothesis
that even in these Divergent organisms
these molecules could be playing a role
as evolutionary conservative centers for
Alpha viruses and allowing them to again
infect a wide range of different species
and so here I'm showing you examples of
experiments we did with them Niki Forest
virus rvps and Eastern equine
Encephalitis rvps in the red and green
respectively I'm showing you the percent
of gfp positive cells when cells um that
uh overexpress human horse bird 80s of
Chip tie or 80s album pictures to
Mosquito species of vldlr or even
something like C elegans which actually
initially was supposed to be our
negative control because we thought the
vldlr ortholog from warm would be
Divergent enough from humans that
perhaps wouldn't work as a receptor
um and uh the set of receptors here are
overexpressed again on capex is the two
cells shown on the right for Eve as well
and hopefully you can see that sfv is
quite promiscuous in being able to use
vldlr orthologies with organisms dating
us far away from humans as the warm
orthologic in this case uh derived from
C elegans while uh Eastern equine
Encephalitis virus rvps were able to
infect a human expressing vldlr of
course but also the two mosquito
Orthodox I'll be tested in this case the
80s egypti and 80s of elbow pictures
so we also wanted to do a similar set of
experiments Within
4 er2 for A4 er2 does not define
ortholog in mosquitoes or other
invertebrates so we only tested Mouse
and bird and hopefully you could see
here that there's an interesting pattern
whereby sfv again seems to be quite
promiscuous in being able to use
multiple of the isoforms we tested and
uh Eve being able to use a horse via uh
for er2 and maybe less silver than Mouse
in this case
and so at the time we're preparing our
paper for publication as you can see was
a lot of work with a lot of controls uh
and you know going in back back and
forth reviewers over about a year and a
half
um another paper came out uh
from Mike diamonds group that got us
really excited this was describing the
role of
ldlr83 as a seller receptive for
Venezuelan equine Encephalitis virus so
this virus like each other Encephalitis
virus causes Encephalitis and horses and
humans also vector by birds also
affected by mosquitoes and so if you
compare vltlr and
ldlr83 this protein that is actually a
are related to ldlr family members
because it contains these repeats but
not as much because it also misses the
core of the EGF beta propeller domains
as well as the Olex sugar domain so it's
really like a minimal form of the
receptor
um
vlblr it's somehow ldlr83 is involved um
over expressing the brain but the
function and role in brain development
is actually poorly characterized and
unknown
uh
uh but Mike diamonds group and others
ultimately through structural analysis
we're able to show that the first repeat
here of this ldlr83 so la repeat one is
able to bond exactly where mxra8 by just
the class between E1 and E2
um but because there's structural
homology between LA repeats found in
ldlr83 and La repeats found in the vlvlr
record domain we wanted to see whether
or not ldlr83 could serve as a receptor
for
other Alpha viruses that use vldlr and
what we saw indeed was that
samliki Forest Eastern Equinox in this
could not use ldlr83 despite their
ability to bind the ligand binding
domains of other Alpha viruses
um
and so uh ultimately I disregated to us
that perhaps there was extensive
co-evolution between each of these
viruses the ligand binding domains of
their receptors but perhaps these had
really co-evolved with using ldlr ID3
and had become specialized with using
that receptor only
so in summary I've showed you that ldlr
related receptors teller receptors were
multiple Alpha viruses got the receptor
ligand binding domain is a site of virus
attachment
um that Divergent receptor ortholox can
support Alpha virus entry and that virus
host core Evolution likely drives
receptor usage patterns and this is work
that we're pursuing now in our lab to
further Define using structural methods
and so there are several members
of the lab both former and current that
I'd like to acknowledge
um there's Lars Clark who was a graduate
student with me but also had to work as
a technician for about a year and a half
before he joined the lab as a PhD
student who really was uh the person to
spearhead this project Chewie and Sarah
she did the original crispr screen he
was a post back in the lab that's moved
on and is working now at beam
Therapeutics and Sarah was also our
graduates who worked closely with Lars
MBA uh quite of an effort in terms of
the number of experiments we did to
really convince ourselves about the role
of the of the lrna for er2 as receptors
for these viruses and Lauren and Sarah
I'm sure we really worked hand in hand
to make this work happen
um Adrian and Catherine all other
graduate students and um these are
additional land members that offered
moral support Paola Montero Lopez at the
Micron core helped us with the
fluorescently labeled virus like
particles Isaac shoes lab with the
cortical neurons I'd not show you these
data but we also worked with Tracy Young
Pearson's Lab at performance hospital to
make uh human neurons derived from stem
cells and show that wrap as well as via
the lrfc fusion proteins could block
entry of seminiki forest virus into
human neurons and Scott Weaver's Lab at
utmp and Scott himself and then
additional collaborative the School of
Public Health and for funding sources
really the valley foundation in the
boroughs welcome are critical to allow
us to carry out this work so I'd be
happy now to get any questions you might
have
thank you so much Dr Abraham for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the live q a of the webinar and if
you have any questions you want to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located at the far left
of your screen so let's get started it
looks like we already have some great
questions coming in
Dr Abraham are there other viruses that
use ldlr related receptors for viral
entry and do they bind the receptor in
the same way
uh yes that's a great question
um so there's two viruses I can think of
top of my head where the sort of
important point to make is one is
vesicular stomatitis virus so this is a
virus that actually when I was a
graduate student was taught not to have
a receptor because it just got into
pretty much every single cell uh you
threw the virus at so it was thought to
actually bind to
um phospholipids but ultimately a lab
was able to show that this virus binds
not only vldlr but also ldlr and other
ldlr related receptors and that virus in
particular also binds a ligand binding
domain and kind of like the Venezuelan
equine Encephalitis virus structure I
showed from like diamonds group
um they bind in a way that engages only
a single repeat at the time although
they can bind multiple repeats as
opposed to just one another example are
human rhinoviruses of certain minor
several groups those can also bind vldlr
specific quickly
and so I think it's an interesting part
of Biology another Point actually Amy
Hartman's lab over
um at the University of Pittsburgh I
believe showed that lrp1 which is
related but more distantly than
um uh ldlrs related to a4er2 and vldlr
lrp1 is a receptor for Rift a valley
fever virus and I'm waiting also I guess
to see maybe follow-up work from that
lab to see exactly how it binds but I
believe it buys a ligand binding domain
in a way that's inhibited by rap so a
lot of viruses seem to hijack on the
hijack a ligand binding domain to get
into cells
thank you so much in our next audience
member wants to know do alpha viruses
have Pandemic potential
uh that's a great question
um
so I would argue so there's some
properties that make certain viruses
more likely to cause pandemics
um I think we've all learned this from
Star scoby too I think any virus that's
respiratory
um poses challenges any virus also that
has a uh ability to affect but in
substantial number of people cause
minimal to no symptoms or asymptomatic
illness or mild symptoms those viruses
also have Pandemic potential so I would
say for uh the ones that are
Encephalitis causing because they're so
highly lethal and people are so
asymptomatic when they get sick I think
it's less likely that those viruses
could cause a pandemic that being said
viruses can always these RNA viruses are
and they could always mutate so for an
example of this is chikungunya virus and
Alpha virus that causes rational
arthritis
um it did not cause a pandemic but
caused very large epidemics in recent
decades including in 2016
um an outbreak in the Americas that led
to over 300 000 cases in that case the
virus causes rash arthritis and it's
spread by mosquitoes but another bit
dementia because as soon as the virus
evolves to be able to spread from Human
to human that's also a game changer so I
think these are all factors to keep in
mind but for now the pandemic potential
is perhaps less than the epidemic
potential which could still be a big
problem
thank you so much and again I want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in we have one more
that has come in from our audience what
makes a virus more likely to cause a
pandemic
I think touching upon these points again
I would say what the Microsoft score
would be two ultimately if the virus is
able to
spread by respiratory droplets if the
virus causes uh asymptomatic or
minimally symptomatic illness and
ultimately the virus can learn to spread
human to human those are all really a
big danger signs I think for example the
next set of the coronaviruses I'd be
looking out for something like Nipa
virus or Hannibal viruses where uh in
recent outbreaks has been demonstrated
human to human transmission by the
respiratory route but not Alpha viruses
just yet these are still mosquito-borne
viruses so big pandemics but not uh big
epidemics but not pandemics
those those pesky mosquitoes
Dr Ibraham thank you so much for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any final comments for our
audience members today
uh I would not have any additional
comments
well we want to thank you very much
again
for your time and for your important
research and before we go I want to
thank our audience for joining us today
and further interesting questions and
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand for two
years until September 8 2024 laboratory
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time take care everyone bye-bye